dann ist luca und herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem ruck beim video
viele von euch wissen wahrscheinlich gar
nicht was das ist im grunde genommen
beantwortet man einfach fragen während
man irgendetwas ist in den meisten
fällen ist das fast food wir haben uns
allerdings einfach spiegeleier und in
welche welt bestellt und beantragt netz
fragen
wie viele paar schuhe habt ihr 40
ich glaube ja so fünf zudem schaust du
auf idol mäßig ständige nicht mich
definitiv nicht wir brauchen nur ein
erstes kalb wegen dir mein herz ist
wegen mir ich bin noch so ein mensch ich
parke salz und pfeffer auf mein essen
preuß über optimiert haben aber das ist
immer zu wenig salz auf immer noch die
frage zurückzukommen du hast gar kein
idol also auch früher nicht gehabt oder
so nicht mehr in justin bieber man darf
doch noch früher wollte ich immer wie
hannah montana sein
ich habe gesagt ohne gewürze
gewürzgurken des gegners das level tanks
einem video der ich glaube geschmack für
die pharmazeutische stoffe geil finden
so aus dem herrscher selbst ich klein
war war mein dad immer mein idol aber
als ich dann so mit youtube angefangen
habe war es dann auf youtube bezogen
casey leistet also einen block aus new
york unangenehmste erlebnis als stalking
sachen es gab auch morddrohungen
ja aber es sind
ich hatte letztes jahr so musste da war
die beziehung von mir nicht öffentlich
ist schon so ein typ bin bei mir vor der
haustür zu hause und ich hat heute die
ganze zeit mich nach einem date gefragt
würde ich über die grenze gesetzt so
nein ich habe einen freund und dann
wurde recht aggressiv und meinte so jahr
ich verfolgte ich schon seit zwei jahren
ist fast kein freund der wollte doch
ganz schnell von der haus direkt ihren
bis dann irgendwann meine mama carmen
weg geschickt hat
die langfassung wer zu lange junge ich
bin gegen pub strohhalme denn das ist so
eine scheiße alles auf plastik aber das
dümmste was wir sagen können dass es
noch was ist eigentlich euer
lieblingsspiel dass unser lieblings
brettspiel mäßig ist noch mal muss man
so würfeln und so sachen einem
kreuzenden wert erst als an der costa
del sol aber zum glück spielt mein
lieblings computerspielen oder dass wir
beide oft gespielt haben war super mario
also ich dachte mainz jetzt ein video
ins spiel was zu jeden morgen spielst ja
auch gern und ndr to play wie viele
kinder wollt ihr bekommen 23 was machst
du mit deiner hamburger wohnung aktuell
befindet sich absolut garnichts seiner
hamburger wohnung da wir alles mit nach
köln genommen haben der plan ist
allerdings dass sich die wohnung auf
dauer entweder vermiete was ist
eigentlich so das was ich vorhabe oder
wenn sie sich ein besseres anlage bums
diese das ergibt dann
verkaufen welche deiner wohnung in
findest du von der einrichtung der lage
am besten also von der lage sind beide
wohnungen top finde ich bei lage ist
wenn ich das wichtigste an allem dann
jeder immobilie findet allerdings die
einrichtung klar jetzt hier hinter
unsere hilfe gar nicht nur einrichtung
gerade zu tun aber finde ich eigentlich
köln besser wenn es notwendig ist weil
ich halt haben wir vorher gebaut habe
und aus hamburg viele learnings
mitgenommen aber nach köln aus dem
baujahr eingeht vom ausblick und alle
möglichen aber auf jeden fall hamburg er
ist motiviert dazu arbeiten
damit er sich die frage übrig habt ihr
schon pläne für die zukunft also das
einzige was zählt ist dass wir
vernünftige köln kommen dass die ganzen
sachen hier aus wollen dass wir alles
machen putzen sauber machen dass wir vor
allem die wohnung fertig machen weil
kleine restarbeiten erledigt werden
müssen und dann mal gucken
arbeiten reisen tel
wo habt ihr euch kennengelernt
ja was nervt euch am jeweils anderen das
zu hübschen für mich bist du kann ich
sehr unaufmerksam ist keine frage aber
beschreibt euch gegenseitig mit einem
wort hübsch
dazu sagt negatives wer gibt mehr geld
für kleidung aus definitiv ich
eher wird es ein paar was magst du so
ein podcast aufnehmen das ding ist halt
das man normalerweise mit leuten
befreundet ist wie die interessen von
einem selber auch vertreten eventuell
die gleichen hobbys haben die gleichen
vorlieben haben im beisein von mir es
ist halt so kommt das ist einfach
dementsprechend total witzig ist mir
diese podcast folge einmal durch nicht
aufziehen weil sonst erzählen sondern
ich echt wirklich fast gar nichts wir
sehen uns zwar häufig wenn ich in köln
bin also jetzt dementsprechend vermehrt
auch öfter aber wir uns eigentlich viel
schöner deren unseren preisen so ein
bisschen klar macht noch viel zusammen
aber dann ist nicht so dass wir uns
werden welche sachen unterhalt und im
podcast wenn wir nicht gezwungen heißt
pro woche fünf minuten und welche dinge
enthalten wären bei allen anderer
ansicht und das ist das was wir so spaß
ich hab noch nie gesehen dass ihr beide
die gleiche meinung von irgendwas hat
geht an minecraft bringt weiter oder
machst du einen neu ist die sache ist
das meinen minecraft mit luca staffel 1
projekt muss weiter gehen wird weil ich
habe gesagt ey das hat mir spaß gemacht
ich will jetzt auch nicht auf krampf das
irgendwie ausschlachten für für geld und
werbung anzeigen keine ahnung was
sonst einfach schön dass das projekt
schon rum das ende gefunden hat bei
folge 100 das ist schön dass es
abgeschlossen das ist genauso wie so
eine serie wo man sagt okay die hat
jetzt ihre drei staffeln und alles
vorbei man kann das ganze noch auslassen
wie prison break oder schreckt oder was
weiß ich was alles aber es wird nicht
besser dadurch deswegen mannschaft mit
lukas leistet auf keinen fall
weitergehen da habt ihr die welt auch
den download bekommen könnte aber ich
will weitermachen möchte minecraft lukas
dafür zwei kann nicht weitergehen weil
ich die welt nicht mehr habe meine pcs
abgepackt und ich habe leider nichts in
der cloud gespeichert seitdem mache ich
das alles aber ich glaube jeder muss
einmal so ein erlebnis haben auch wenn
mein handy verliert das man dann erst
weiße kennedy als bilder daten sind
denke ich brauche geklaut oder die
gesundheit um einfach wie lukas staffel
3 wird auf jeden fall im winter starten
herbst winter jetzt nicht im sommer weil
das ist mir hier auch ich hoffe ich habe
zu viel stress sie mit der wohnung in
anderen projekten und dann irgendwann so
herbst winter jetzt nur warum warst du
nicht auf der globe überhaupt der globe
aber ich bin nicht mit dem messer
gelaufen weil
wenn er sich so nach diesem schminke
verein bist du aus waren laut wir waren
eigentlich auswendig kennt man keine
antwort weiß wäre das einzige was ich
mir vorstellen könnte außerhalb von
deutschland in deutschland haben alles
uns geht so gut wieder beschwert sich
immer über das wetter oder übersteuern
alter dann geht doch dann geht doch
woanders hingeht doch ein anderes an
alle kommen früher oder später zurück
auch wenn leute sagen steuern zurück ja
wenn du wieder super deutsche
mittelstand hat so das ist ja dann dreht
sich die kamera ich bin soweit am rand
was ist eure lieblings passt nach vorn
ich glaube
diese großen muscheln wir haben mit
diesen auch bibel teuer da sind so
richtig großen google aber es handelt
sich perfekt suchst du drin oder wenn
man irgendwas anderes kommt so plötzlich
so gemüse so ein bisschen in der fast
alle drin weil er sonst nämlich auch
diese kleinen cappellini heißen die die
müssen nur drei minuten lang kochen das
sind so richtig dünn die find ich auch
wie lange dauern die bauarbeiten ist
eigentlich sollten sie schon fertig sein
soll sich schon im märz fertig sein dann
kamen die ukraine russland konflikt und
corona doch noch mit reingespielt
deswegen wird es dann auf juni
verschoben und jetzt auf dem august und
ich sehe der besitzen wir noch eine
halbe baustelle aber die meisten sachen
die hier mit 70 sachen von mir also 99
prozent der wohnung sind fertig terrasse
wird erst im september gemacht und sauna
punkt sind auch noch nicht richtig aber
wenn alles läuft kommen vielleicht oder
zeigen wer von euch verträgt mehr
alkohol der punkt ist dass ich fast nie
trinken
luca verträgt auch gar nichts das
nächste kugel im körper trägt alkohol
und ich trinke nie
du bist so schnell voll trinks 5 mit
einem planeten was würde der als beruf
machen wenn nicht youtube also
verhindert hat eine ausbildung als
bürokauffrau und
industriekauffrau bei der deutschen bahn
gemacht deswegen wirst du denke ich in
irgendeiner richtung arbeiten ist und
worauf jeden fall ich habe marketing
management studiert weil ich mir halt
schon damals frist oder gedacht habe er
mit youtube wenn das wetter lockt bleibt
ganz cool es kann mich ganz gut
supporten hat schlussendlich auch was
ich habe viele viele sachen mitgenommen
aus dem studium in ganz hätte ich aber
wenig youtube nicht gemacht hätte hätte
ich auch das nicht studiert sondern
hätte wahrscheinlich architektur
studiert und da hätte ich auch richtig
spaß gefunden
wie ihr seht die einrichtung ist dann
hast du das erste mal peyton gesehen und
was war deine reaktion erst mal richtig
auf der saarmesse gesehen da sagst du
irgendwo auf dem sofa des todes arrogant
austro das budget und ich dafür aber mit
so einem mädchen alter da will ich gar
nichts mehr zu tun haben sympathisch
dabei gehandelt einfach nur bestätigt an
der stelle würden wir das heutige video
ist ob er in meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat wie wir endlich mal
auch ein video gemacht haben das haben
sind einige gewünscht die anderen wissen
alle gar nicht was das ist also das
irgendwie mode hassen sowieso ein
bisschen ich fasste sie schließlich auch
egal auf jeden fall konntet ihr glaube
ich ein bisschen was über uns lernen
wenn noch weitere fragen da sind
spazieren und in die kommentare
vielleicht erstmal noch mal so
belastet berges und stinken daher dann
zum frühstück dann machen wir nochmal so
ein video ansonsten sehen wir uns
entweder heute auf 1 2 wieder da ging
nämlich auch ein video online auf lupus
wird er oft den kopf
verlieren und ja weihnachten noch ein
fremdwort ist
für dich vielleicht